[Music]
you
good morning someone I don't even know
who I'm talking to anymore
Maureen thank you goodbye thank you for
being a part of Logue brothers during
John's paternity leave and John hello
I missed you we all missed you welcome
back I hope that you don't hate us for
taking you away from Henry but here you
are come back to us I missed you man I
really did so that Google search story I
felt like I had to do it as soon as I
saw the Super Bowl ad I was like there's
got to be a harry potter version of one
of these and then I looked and there
wasn't and so I made one and I hope that
you all enjoyed it I'm not going to say
very much today I'm just going to let
the search story stand on its own a
little bit but John I'm really glad that
you're back I'm really excited to have
our Brotherhood renewed I'm looking
forward to your next video I'm expecting
it to be awesome so don't let me down
John I will see you on Monday